meeting we audio recorded should be
required to evacuate the building would
you please leave the room by the door
the fire escape safe place please hold
both Sandra I was in case of stairs or
where so slippery if anyone is able to
use the stairs when they please allow
others to exit if it is unable to use
the stairs but they please allow us to
exceedingly before they go to the four
escaped or where they can in be given
assistance now assembly point will be in
the public car park at the side of the
Civic sweet please do not delay your
evacuation to collect any belongings and
please do not return to the building
until given permission to do so by
counts with staff right Phyllis item i
have is really very sad one as we know
jus Lucas school passed away the weekend
shock to us all and I think we need to
give some respect to jewel you know to
remember her as we do so I'd like
everyone just to stand for a minute
sighs
I think Betsy thank you very much thanks
everybody for that right first item of
business is apologist for a sense I
think cuts lisanna stuff is expected
here so we pass in front of olin but we
go up ah Jesus even Keith Hudson and
from your sleep attitude of it was none
of them okay right not members attending
there are none that I welcome to new
google com it but it to the meeting held
on the fifteenth of July is it your wish
I'd sign that as a true record Gregory
like are there any declarations of
interest please this place should i need
to declare an interest in item six
process rewarding Monty yeah okay fine
thank you i'll obviously there's to your
connections with ropes and other
charities okay thank you right if
there's anything that members recognizes
a an interest during the meeting please
declare e at that point we make sure
it's included the mates so sure here
item 6 i think i would occur and
it was obviously i am involved with a
lot of challenges so just in case they
come up very interesting I can't thank
you very much well sure there will be I
don't think you've got the same interest
in you expect to do payroll be able to
be good okay thank you very much you
need alright so straight to have six
then I don't think there are any other
message we further aren't chairman
rather item six then so this is the
process for a warning voluntary sector
job or bronze anybody have an important
service to raise places please consider
this tension really with reference to
all of these we give to charities that
aren't including as hard cash or money
what we're giving kind like free parking
spaces for accommodation rate reductions
I think that needs to be registered with
everything else that we do give in
figures because that also has a value on
towards the various charities I think
there is a certain amount of that done
already turnover when I go to the
meetings where we're deciding on the
criteria using the criteria relating to
people receiving the ground that is part
of the process that we could but I think
it's right that you know for instance
doing new car parking spaces does that
an organization within our areas you
know are other things if you like do
they use our notes it's small but do
they get to use a photocopy machine
which I said after least one these are
things i think that we should take into
consideration I think you're absolutely
right and raising that if I'm convert
you please take that needs to be shown
and so the public can actually see that
as well on top of what we actually give
you talking architecture I can't I agree
with you I members great on that is
pleasing in thank
Jim yes interesting because a member for
cynically several years back one of my
residents actually correct hold of me to
say very disappointed with the fact that
a crime had gone down you know basically
when the graphs were given it was
actually quite a large proportion of a
vehicle grant and it would seem I quite
agree with what price except I've said
that we need to actually monetize those
things in kind that are given so that
residents and and even you know
volunteers for civ4 revs actually
understand you know what they're getting
over and above thank you thank you very
much d je ne chairman and I just want to
do is just a question where we are in
commissioning process that we were
looking at for Rev sincerely or our for
actually providers or two servers
support ever see anything just in the
probe with 45 activities and paid to
view supply you them tomorrow and
prospect to Andrew briefly couple days
back we're right in the middle of the
process if I'm a firming sense so
shouldn't be this [ __ ] without on Bobby
the Danes teacher and does that affect
this was a separate commissioning
processes in its party advise you as you
recall yes so they're still going to
look to top slice well unless members
say that they wished have made you go
from somewhere else I think you send a
report it's being top slice oh yes it is
hidden yeah the only other point I'd
raise if I may is that there are other
organizations that give to various
groups be there are the authorities or
other charity groups that give
two organizations I think that's one
thing we really need to give a
consideration to if we are aware that
certain charities are receiving money
for other sources and very often that's
part of the form that they get any way
they can say who else they've applied
for we need to make sure there's a fair
distribution and we're not supporting
one charity the market of a fair amount
support from elsewhere shall we say so
that's one thing that we need to
consider going forward homemakers agree
with that okay there any other questions
please okay so as far as the decision
being recommended is it agreed main
ingredients okay thank you very much
indeed I think go to item 7 and maybe
the beginning in this is the local town
council tax support scheme relating to
the public consultation that we're going
to undertake I think members have the
figures they're relating to and the
details of what's going out in the
consultation which I thought blushing
members will note so it's not actually
deciding anything at all relating to any
of those figures it's really just the
details of the consultation as going out
right over to you it's me strength
likely times on the an appendix page 7
11 there's a number of questions there
which I can't see the relevance of and
ethnic origins gender sexual orientation
religion
and what what relevance is this too what
role in the tournament Custer this
impress their Sunday the layout of this
consultation illusion sorry the layout
of the consultation is following the
standard standard process and this is
just a general ethnic minority
monitoring for that would be standard in
all consultations if I make sure what
would be information being useful in
relative in relation to this
consultation I think it will be trying
to capture the views of those groups
that may be adversely affected
interactively just monitoring the
responses from the various groups that's
just actually used in daytime really so
this or minority groups and ethnic
groups and would have a 10 days object
may not just be minority groups cheerios
it's also another selling items that's
definitely I thought it not being
exclusive you know absolutely free
capture so protected characteristics
Bruce and just kind of the information
this transitional for it specifically
okay oh yeah be with that i'm not
totally i think i still don't see the
relevance in it in this context i mean
some surveys yet often see irrelevance I
thought I have these will it put people
off responding it would be the opposite
well the point I'd raise if I mean is
that I mean if people don't actually
answer those questions are we still
accepting their realizing okay because I
mean that's something that you know
click I don't want to reject somebody if
they're not prepared to admit you know
that they follow a particular group if
you like something that's the question I
would ask so the answer's no ok let's
fashion but on take away I'll start from
the little my name take Joe first please
oh no sorry chairman okay thank you Jim
is just a comment aside that you say
there's almost most of the guys now um
yeah and it's their choice within my
answer indeed in yeah but I wouldn't
want to be rejected that no no no I feel
on your sign is almost yeah I'm so much
I know actually when we all get a of
forms relating to you no surveys etc
this is what you say please in a general
I notice it has drop across it which
means it is not a finished number of
bringing it down yes yes oh so in that
case would it be fair to say in policy
is not obligatory don't you use a bit
better not literature or a different one
apology yeah but had two negatives in
there
okay before I'm children come up with a
form of words that he doesn't these
things yeah yeah as to the content of
their I think that's presumably for
another diet if you like as as far as
know deciding where we go with our
future or cts coverage any help we might
give as far as a survey responses will
be collecting coming back to the
executive my anticipate that being I
think it's around full of any kind of
scientist David it will be scheduled to
come back on enough sun will be entirely
effective to make a make a decision okay
so this is alpha consultation up to so
we got mr. day so we're anticipate that
we'll be able to start the consultation
at the end of sep tember and you know
all be consultation with dr. expansive
and collector is poison compact
reporting remember meeting and help me
on our website and i don't know if it be
in our newspaper that goes out with it I
got Jessica poor I am I mean I'm just
wanna make sure we can get as much
coverage as we can which I think it's
only fair and you know if any hard to
reach groups you know can be comforted
by anyway I think that's very relevant
as well if I by Chinese companies that
was one thing thank chairman and I have
10 power 5 each groups but and most
options an FPSO gels yes so the agronomy
sounds amazing asset to the force back
yeah so you just for the benefit that
ever since trade you have the labels as
you like having that doesn't have any
matches yet thank you claim uglier
although they get
ok any other points on that meant mins
members happy to support the decision
being recommend regulars ok thank very
much that's when we ends the meeting
thank you very much useful there was an
awful lot to consider in this meeting so
you know if it's very quick meeting so
thank you very much indeed